one of the things that I'll be honest
with you surprised me when I did your
show in person afterwards I said mate
now that we're good mates how about you
on block me on Twitter yeah and you went
oh I've blocked you on Twitter and I
went yeah I made I took the piss out of
you over covid and that's when you
surprise it because you went yeah I
deserved it yeah I did not expect that
actually given your public personas I've
changed my mind on a few things with
kovid because the science changed so
I'll give an example and I'm quite happy
to admit this and talk about it and
people's like ah there you go yeah
because to me it changed so I'll give
you a classic example
I uh when they said that vaccines
couldn't transmit the virus I said okay
right in that case anyone who doesn't
have the vaccine right now represents a
clear and present threat to spreading
this virus and killing people so your
selfish bastards and I'm going to call
you out on that and by the way those who
do have the vaccine they should have
more freedoms because they're not going
to better transmit it once they've had
the Jack you are and you don't care
very strong very emphatic based on a
completely erroneous scientific
assessment which was it couldn't now you
might say well you shouldn't have said
it anyway I would sort of agree I would
say something else actually which is I
think that you have a duty to be
skeptical as a journalist that is your
job I've learned a lesson in the
pandemic about that definitely
definitely and I would totally accept
that I think I was too strident anyway
got two kind of wrapped up in it all but
you know I had good reasons for it I had
you know one of my colleagues at Good
Morning Britain Kate garraway her
husband was in a coma from covid I have
four or five friends and family who lost
loved ones how to say goodbye to their
parents on FaceTime and Care Homes where
they ripped through and so on so I was
very like emotionally invested in it
probably too much so for a journalist I
accept that but on that key point of the
transmission the scientists then said
but later actually it turns out there's
not much difference between whether
you've had the jab or not for
transmission and at that point I
realized everything I've been saying was
completely wrong
and completely unfair and then it
becomes a personal choice if you want to
now again someone will say well it
should be a personal choice anyway well
yeah yeah
but if we had for example as one of the
Oxford AstraZeneca professors put it to
me if this had been the plague come back
with a 30 to 40 death rate including
kids
how would people feel then if we had a
vaccine that was proven to be largely
successful and stopped transmission
and people were refusing to have it and
we were seeing not 3 000 people die a
day but 50 000 died a day I would say
that people's views of that argument
might change quite you wouldn't need to
force anyone to take a vaccine if it was
the plate because right so what my point
being that the argument
would play slightly better if there were
much higher numbers of people dying
right which would come back to my sort
of thing that if the principles are
principal it doesn't really it shouldn't
really matter what the scale is but I
totally accept my rhetoric was over the
top and I think that people once it was
known that you could transmit it whether
you've been jabbed or not I think it's
entirely your personal decision to then
have the vaccine or not and that's a
complete u-turn on what I thought but
the scientists of the U-turn so I was
basing all my emphatic passionate
rhetoric of what I believe desires to be
another lesson from the pandemic science
evolves facts change they find out more
information I don't think as some people
do that all scientists are evil I don't
think they're deliberately setting out
to mislead people I think they're trying
to get to the truth it was a novel virus
early on when there were no vaccines and
no hope of any there's never been a
coronavirus vaccine so in those first
few months when people were dying in big
numbers there were no therapeutic drugs
really no vaccine and it looked
incredibly serious for mankind at that
point I felt the only answer was the
blunt instrument of a lockdown as it
went on I think the argument for
lockdown became less and less convincing
and I always believed that all the
subsidiary effects of lockdown on other
health issues heart disease
uh cancer and so on we're going to come
back and and Haunt It the question then
was where was the pendulum on that deal
look Francis and I both supported the
first lockdown and actually someone
quote tweeted a tweet of mine from the
very first moments when I was saying we
need to work together and stop thinking
solely about ourselves and and people
are now using that against me so I know
I know that the position that you're in
but I think the one thing sticking with
the theme of Freedom that we've been
talking about that I found very
concerning is the amount of censorship
that was happening of scientists very
prominent scientists including Noble
David Davis who was a guest on our show
I made this point Nobel prize-winning
scientist being censored for talking
about things that are in their area I
agree right all of this I totally agree
I totally agree I think that was
um it was everyone slightly lost their
minds yeah
and people will say well you're banging
on about Freedom where were you for the
freedom of people to espouse these you
didn't agree with on kovid and it's a
tricky one when a lot of people are
dying but of course the whole point of
fighting for freedom is sometimes a lot
of people die for Freedom so I can I
totally accept that and I've evolved my
opinion if it was another Health crisis
I would probably behave rather
differently I think we all would yeah
that's true it's the same I would say
the same thing about
um when I campaigned against guns in
America I was a British guy telling
Americans how to lead their lies they
have 420 million guns we have hardly any
and so what do I really know about their
gun culture the truth is I thought I
knew better than them and shouted them
louder and louder to try and get them to
give up guns and they sold more and more
guns because of my shouting so the
complete opposite effect to what I
thought and if I had my time again I
would dial down the rhetoric and I would
try and have a much more open and
constructive debate or I would even
suggest to stop calling it gun control
call it gun safety how do you make it
safer I know you can't take all the guns
away so how do we make it safer much
more interesting conversation than a
British guy who was an accident like
mine we'd been driven out with guns to
get them Independence in the first place
um Jay Leno got it right with me I think
he said to me please look the smart
crowded like LA and and New York the
small liberals he said we can't have all
agree with you right you're right it's
Madness this gun's thing it's madness he
said but most of the rest of America
thinks who's this snotty British guy
with this British accent telling us what
to do so it'd be like you're going to
Germany and saying they can't speed on
the Autobahn again the smart liberals be
like he's right too many people die on
the Autobahn people we should reduce
speed and the rest of Germany's going I
don't want to hear this from this guy
and I definitely don't want to hear it
from my accent and um he's right he was
right it would be like an American
coming over here and saying I want a
bang Cricket because you know people
people get injured and what would we do
we said start off annoying American go
back to him you know that's what we
would think right so I broke that sort
of cultural rule which is you don't go
to someone's restaurant and you don't go
to someone's house and tell them their
curtains suck you might think but anyway
I hope they'd change their curtains but
you just don't shout at them yours your
curtains are disgusting because it's
it's their cat
um so I think that I've I've learned
definitely through that I've learned
through the pandemic that it's the
primary function of a journalist is to
be skeptical of everything
and to be open to all opinions you know
I would qualify it slightly there were a
lot of demented anti-vacular who are
completely implacably opposed to all
vaccines who were peddling utter lies
about the vaccines and I so I make no
apology for taking them head-on they
were really the people I was targeting
but when I look back at some of my
tweets
around the issue of vaccine transmission
I made a presumption the science was
always going to stay the same and when
it changed I was made to look stupid and
dictatorial and freedom bashing and all
the things that I hate
and that was a wake-up call
wake up
[Music]